[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the 60-second dark horse
podcast live stream q and a
in the middle of whatever it is that's
taking place
yep that's right well we got cat madness
we do have cat madness
for those of you who watched the initial
part of the broadcast let me just say
i have looked and that harper's article
that we were talking about
does indeed look like it's from 2018
although in my defense the article
itself does not have a date on it so the
fact that the author tweeted it today
um led me to think this was current so
anyway i'm
sure what he said is true but
nonetheless a couple years back and like
i said i'm familiar
um you know we are decades old uh
subscriber to harpers and walter kern
has written many of those
opening essays and it's really quite
excellent so um
uh i'm i did not know that he was no
longer writing for harper's i hadn't
noticed
it's been a lot going on there has been
a lot going on yeah um even though it's
two years ago
i got two plus years ago at this point
but anyway um
i recommend for people who aren't
familiar with him finding his writing
he's quite good walter kern
all right let us begin with a few
questions from
episode 61 question from the discord and
then move into questions from last hour
hmos are now woke how can one get safe
healthcare now
do we let our diseases play out caveman
style or are we not there yet
i'm in california incidentally on hmo
through medicaid expansion with several
conditions so this obviously what is it
how are we supposed to get healthcare
and it's not just the healthcare
question but the insurance question sort
of
all tied up um this is a many
lifetimes question yes um you gotta
well what i would say i mean i think
you're headed in exactly the right
direction which is yes this is very
frightening when it comes to health care
it's also
very frightening when it comes to
everything else
and the very fact you know we have
um banking that is not
immune to this we have uh you know the
ability to source
basic human needs and the problem you
know as we were alluding to in the
in the initial part of the podcast is
that
the dangerous ideology that appears to
want to control
access to well-being and shunt it this
way and away from that way and is
pursuing something it calls equity and
then
all of that that um
that ideology
is unfortunately being
emboldened by the conservative response
that says
private property rights are paramount
and
private property rights are important
but to make them paramount and make
everything else subservient to them
effectively means that um
well as i was talking to a good friend
of ours
yesterday you may have the right to
drive on the road because it's public
but that doesn't mean you have the right
to
tires right tires are not public and so
in a world where yeah i mean i think the
point is
reductio ad absurdum is really the thing
that you need to
avail yourself of because we're headed
in such an absurdum direction
that you know we're going to land in
these you know that's not how latin
works right
uh it is now okay you know because uh
the romans who's gonna stop you yeah
exactly and pharmacists
i don't see that happening so yeah um
i guess i had i had two comments about
this question that are not exactly what
you said um and i don't
remember the first the second one um
the first one with regard to you know do
we let our diseases play out caveman
style are we not there yet
i have said and you have as well for
for many many years that
western medicine has a few amazing
successes and with those few amazing
successes
it um has imagined that it actually
knows more than it really does
and those amazing successes come in two
broad categories
one is surgery knife work um
and the other is um
the pretty narrow slice of uh
pharmaceutical interventions that are
antibiotics and vaccines
and you know i i say that you know even
you know with our conversations
about vaccines that we've been having
but like really antibiotics and vaccines
and surgery um in combination and you
know and things like a germ theory of
disease and you know before
before many of the things about what
pharmaceuticals can do for us got over
applied
and rendered doctors um sort of script
readers and
script and script givers many
many more medical doctors i think were
great diagnosticians
which is what you know we need we need
scientists doing medicine
as opposed to people who have memorized
a book of symptoms that may or may not
have been described
through an actual scientific process so
if you have a condition that is actually
going to benefit from an antibiotic
or vaccine or from surgery uh
you should absolutely find the best
primary health care provider you can and
and
you know allow them to know you well
enough such that they will be able to
tell you when in fact you have for
instance a bacterial infection that
warrants an antibiotic
um or you're going to a place that you
need you know these vaccines whatever it
is
um i have found and this
again is a you know you know books long
careers long
certainly many more than a couple of
sentences long
um conversation that is warranted but in
the wake
of two major uh medical
things that happened to me five years
ago now when i ruptured my achilles
tendon playing ultimate
frisbee and then four gosh now four and
a half years ago
um almost dying in the galapagos in a
boat accident
which caused such you know such all body
destruction across
almost every system except my head i
have found
so many health care providers
who don't come looking the way that we
are told health care providers the most
excellent health care providers are
necessarily going to look
and this ranges from an amazing do
a do being an alternative degree to md
which has
all of the same privileges in terms even
in terms of like
prescription granting um but just is
coming from
a tradition that is more that spends
more time with patients and is more
hands-on
um through all manner of you know there
are certainly
lots of quacks out there in every in
every realm but
an excellent physical therapist or
chiropractor or
even acupuncturist um structural
integration therapists and
all of these things myofascial release
have the ability to actually
the health of a system of a body more
than
a doctor with a prescription pad and 10
minutes to hear what your complaint is
and assess whether or not they
have that in their um you know in in
their file um
that said most modern insurance won't
pay for
all of these alternative practices and
so we're really kind of
screwed honestly all right i want to say
two things let's follow up to that
one uh or maybe it's three things one
is i know you to be somebody who will
try things that people find
effective and reject them when they
don't work yeah so there's several
things i've tried
right to the extent you you know you are
not kidding yourself because i
definitely know you to
come back from such things and say no i
don't think that that
that helped second thing is
the comparison to so-called cavemen
is an interesting one it cuts both ways
and
uh the you know your caveman ancestors
your pleistocene
ancestors would have been thoroughly
jeopardized
by bacterial infections right a wound
could be very serious because it could
turn to gangrene which can kill you very
easily
the ability to treat such things with
antibiotics is
amazingly powerful a huge gift yeah
but this modern world that has given us
antibiotics
has also given us things like air travel
so the extent to which we are far sicker
far more regularly because we are in
contact with all of these things that
would be circulating in some little
place you'd never hear of them
but suddenly they're everywhere it has
robbed us even
the modern world has robbed us even as
it has given us uh
new tools to fight disease it has given
us a great many more diseases that we
have to worry about
so that's significant i also want to say
you know i of course agree and have said
that
that you know basically medicine has
these
great successes vaccines antibiotics
and surgery being the most major of them
but i want to point out that each of
those is actually
us utilizing a built-in biological
near miracle right and wielding it well
the antibiotics are
chemical warfare agents that are being
made by bacteria
and fungi to fight each other and we can
use them
to fight on our behalf surgery
is basically entirely dependent on
the magical process of wound healing in
which we can actually
cut into you remove a tumor and then
you will magically you know reassemble
yourself in a way that if you think
about
doing such a thing on a car or an
airplane is
you'll realize just how amazing it is
that your body has this
this capacity so anyway i guess the
point is
oh and vaccines trade on the ability of
the immune system to be alerted ahead of
time to something that it would
ordinarily just acquire information
about through getting sick
um so anyway we do this but we're using
medicine at its best is basically
surfing a beautiful biological substrate
that uh evolved and is there for us to
improve
in concert with our bodies as opposed to
acting like an engineer and going like
how can i how can i brute force this
thing into submission
right yeah the arrogance of thinking
that what we're doing is taking a
biological system that ain't so great
and intervening in a way that makes it
better that's just
a garbage nonsense notion and we should
get over it
well i mean it comes from the same
people who say things like we only use
10 of our brands
and a vast majority of people have a
chemical imbalance in their brains that
needs to be fixed with exogenous drugs
really you must not have been around for
very long or understand anything about
science or evolution if you believe
either of those things
well i've come to a different conclusion
about
the claim that we use 10 of our brains i
think people who
say that are when they say it using
about 10
of their only when they say it though
yeah now you're being generous well some
of them say it a lot so
next question doesn't the politically
driven
narrative maintaining withholding of a
known effective treatment prophylactic
like evermechtin
arguably amount to negligent
manslaughter how many would still be
alive if given early treatment
so this again is from last episode when
we spent some time talking about ever
mechtin last week
yeah um yeah um i would say
potentially so here's what i want
everybody to get the nuance the job
of deciding what drugs might
possibly be wielded what evidence is
sufficient in order to justify them
being prescribed
this is not a job you want right because
you will kill people no matter what you
do
right and there are lots of jobs that
are true that for which this is true
but my point would be this is a job that
is impossible to do
perfectly and that means people will die
as a result of whatever decisions you
make on the other hand it doesn't mean
that you can't make those decisions
really really badly either as a result
of ineptitude or more likely as a result
of corruptions in the system that cause
you to see things one way when you
should see them another way
and so i don't know why you know hey
it's possible
that the information we have on
ivermectin is actually misleading in
some way that we don't know it's
possible there's something we could see
that would cause us to re-evaluate what
we think we know
on the other hand if the evidence that
we've seen is
representative then it does appear that
at least we have
um gross negligence that is going to
result in
lots of loss loss of health and loss of
life
and it so yes potentially is the answer
not necessarily okay
what are the evolutionary reasons for
comedy and laughter
in general and how did with time people
come to appreciate dark humor
so again excuse me every week i pick
some of the ones that we weren't able to
get to the previous week
and because i'm going through the
sometimes
dozens of questions we weren't able to
get to these are often ones that
we we should want to spend many hours on
but we only have a couple of minutes so
so um i i can't remember exactly when it
was but i
advanced the hypothesis on the meaning
of laughter and humor
um at least a decade ago and as i was
describing it to somebody they actually
pointed to a quote
that um wasn't exactly identical to it
but uh
certainly was in the same neighborhood
and it was uh tom stoppard
who said laughter is the sound of
comprehension
and um god oh that's beautiful i hope
that's
i hope that's true tom stepart is one of
my favorites yeah yeah and it's exactly
a tom stoppard kind of insight so anyway
the hypothesis that i deployed was that
effectively
um so a the thing to pay attention to
is comedy timing which i'm not going to
claim to understand i don't think
anybody understands it really
there are some experts in wielding it
but as to what exactly it's made of
you can't do it explicitly right like
you're not if you if you go conscious on
it it's like catching a frisbee
consciously
yes but i don't even think that an
expert in it can describe what it is
that makes for excellent timing and what
it is that makes for just slightly off
timing that causes a joke to fall flat
you know when you see it right um so
in any in any case what i would say is
that funny things
are things at the fringe of
consciousness that is to say there are
things that we are conscious of to one
degree or another but we are very often
not conscious that others are conscious
of it too
and so when somebody says something
um that is funny such that a room or a
group erupts in laughter
what it effectively is is a bunch of
people signing on
to a recognition that yes they are aware
of the same little
oddity and
if one attempts to be part of the group
by signing on to these things by
laughing when you don't really
understand what it is that's being said
you will out yourself
right um because you will laugh
incorrectly
and the point is there is something
the way that a you know i i always when
i make a joke and it's really
good right i have the sense that it
causes a kind of
whiplash the brain thinks it's going in
this direction then suddenly
changes direction and it really oh
that's not what it was and
um that whiplash you know the sort of
the snap of it
is what makes the joke really funny and
so if you bungle the timing it's you
know sort of
you know you ooze around the curve but
you're i mean you're making a population
level analysis there's there's two
things here right there's
um there's what what it does to reveal
an individual's comprehension per
stoppard's observation
but then it's about um unifying and
synchronizing
a group such that not only are people
who aren't
in the same kind of no reveal themselves
as not being in the same kind of no
but you also become more synchronous
going forward and maybe better able to
deal with an enemy a hunt whatever it is
come together and make an important
political decision for the group
whatever it is right
yes well it goes it goes with the
hypothesis which we
uh have outlined in various places and
is in our our upcoming book
about the nature of consciousness itself
that consciousness is most fundamentally
collective
and that individual consciousness is
secondary
and so yes what is a group made of it's
a group of people who
basically share conscious space and how
do you you know
bump out the edge of some part of that
consciousness well often we do it with
humor we
tread around the edges of things that
aren't quite understood or aren't quite
comfortable to talk about
and um somebody who does it well you
know i mean if you think about what the
classic comedian does right
they spend their life thinking about
things that the rest of us find mundane
and noticing you know if you didn't find
that mundane and you thought carefully
about it you re you'd realize how absurd
you look doing that right and so
um yep so anyway something like that uh
so what is the nature of uh
you know dark humor which is that this
process
knows no boundaries right it covers all
of the topics that are most difficult to
deal with all of the frightening stuff
and all of the embarrassing stuff and
all of that those you know in fact
you know you can do comedy cheaply in
some sense if you just go to one of
these areas where people are
like deliberately blinded to some set of
truths and you
you know you out them yep
how do you think masks affect people
how do you think masks affect people
wolves perceptions of us
would puppies born recently be affected
with regard to the ability to read the
behavior of strangers
so people wolf is our term for
our domestic dogs including ours here
lying on the floor that you guys can't
see
um so how do you think that masks affect
people's perceptions of us
uh it's a great question um i am not
sure because
i don't really know i mean in some ways
we have argued that dogs are the most
conscious non-human
animals domestic dogs are
because they interface with us and so in
some sense our
collective consciousness extends to them
in weird asymmetrical ways
and it is also i think quite clear
that the facial architecture of dogs has
evolved in response to
human sensitivity to facial expressions
it doesn't mean it goes the other way
around
right you know the eternal sad eyes
that the labrador gives us even when
she's
obviously happy it results in her
getting a good many
things just so that we can stop feeling
so damn guilty about how we mistreat the
dog which we don't
but and even she doesn't think we
mistreat her yeah but her eyes still a
different story her eyes tell a very
different story
but you know all the little gestures i
mean this dog has incredible eyebrows
right the ability to raise one eyebrow
it's just on beyond any human i've ever
known
but the point is okay we process their
facial expressions which has caused
them to gain presumably it's not a
conscious control but a subconscious
control over the musculature in their
face in a way that a wild animal
wouldn't have
i don't know if they're processing our
facial expressions
they process our voices they process our
voices and
they um probably process aspects of
our endocrinological system that we
aren't aware of
given their much better sense of both
smell and the addition of that
the other chemical scent the vomeronasal
organ um that you know
if we're agitated even if we're not
saying it um they may well be able to
smell that agitation
right and you know hey mom why do you
smell frightened yeah like you
you could see agitation on my face but
she could maybe smell it on me
right right totally um i think that's
likely now
even if they don't process our facial
expressions
um and you know what this raises a
really good question
this raises all sorts of questions about
um you know what about
those of us who you know are constantly
joking around
by saying preposterous things and you
know trying to keep a straight face
while we do it you know
we're very misleading with our facial
expressions you know that would tend to
throw a dog
if they were processing them well now
only if they were processing both the
facial expressions and the language
and that's imagine that they have rather
a lot more language on board than anyone
thinks
yeah no no i it doesn't really it
imagines
that um there is information in one's
demeanor
and that somebody who is abusing that
channel in order to make jokes
uh is basically noise with respect to a
dog who doesn't care much for the jokes
you know at least so far um
and uh you know you can't therefore read
actual information about your
your mental state yeah um but i think i
mean frankly the smells
the smells are less likely to lie right
like we as humans
as primates with less ability
to sense smells are less likely to be
able to lie with them to obscure
our emotional state our hormonal state
via smells
and so they're more likely to have an
active an active route into
what we actually are feeling even if we
are not aware of it yes so
if they are processing our facial
expressions that we are
assuming are targeted at another no
we're liars right like
they're probably walking around all the
time thinking who does she think she's
fooling
right like all the other apes right
that's all just the other dogs
right but there is a question a dog even
if they don't process the facial
expressions they could process the fact
of masks and the pattern of when we put
them on and when we take them off and
how we feel about them you know we all
resent them and
uh feel relief at taking them off and
then why are we putting them on and why
don't we wear them in
in the house and why do we wear them in
the house when somebody comes in
right all those things you know those
are questions a dog could potentially
ponder
and uh you know the problem is the dogs
are isolated from each other so they
can't discuss what the answers might be
that's true yeah i'm not going to spend
too much time worrying about that
yeah i guess i won't do that okay uh
discord question for this week before
uh launching into the questions from
today
why are beauty standards so diverse
between cultures
is it natural genetics or marketing for
example thin european women versus
larger more curvy hips
and behinds being the rage in america
um um again lots lots of places to go
here yeah there's there's a lot of
everything
in the answer to this question a there
are certain things that are um
i'm trying to come up with objective
language but there's certain things that
are more beautiful than other things in
objective terms there are other things
which are arbitrary and are
hallmarks of um you know
membership and you know lots of stuff
that is processed
you know you would expect men and
women to process things that are proxies
for
stuff that matters right and so like
across cultures
particular ways to hip ratios and women
um
regardless of whether or not the
preference is for a thinner purse a
thinner women or
larger women still the hip to the waist
to hip ratio
preferences are more or less stable um
which
is suggestive of an interest totally
unconscious presumably
in fertility right um uh breasts too
although i think there's a persistent
paradox with this one
which is to a point larger breasts
are something that you would expect men
to be
interested in because they are a proxy
for the
amount of resource necessary to produce
a baby which is not a small amount of
resource which doesn't mean that the
resources in the breast
go into the baby but it means that a
woman whose breasts are large
or larger than some threshold
has those resources on board um
but but not i mean that's that's only
true when you're actually actively
breastfeeding nope i would say not i
would say
i don't there's no evidence that size of
breasts outside of
having a baby at the breast is
predictive of how much milk you can
produce
i think they're no no it's not a
question of how much milk you can
produce it's a question of how much
excess resource so for those who are
okay so um
a human females are the only mammals in
which breast tissue is
enlarged when not lactating so that's a
fascinating and important fact
um but anyway therefore clearly sexually
selected right therefore clearly
sexually selected
it is a an advertisement it is an
advertisement of the presence of
resources but what i don't quite get and
i don't get it
either as you know a red-blooded male or
as a scientist is why
above some threshold there seems to be
this obsession with bigger is better
right that doesn't add up right to the
extent that a woman
has in some way physiologically
demonstrated the resources to produce a
baby
that would seem to be like a check box
rather than you know the bigger the
better so i don't understand why
that seems to be a a priority that
many men seem to uh well this this will
end up being a cultural difference and
it is i mean it is a bit
peacocky right um that you know the the
big showy
tna versus uh a more slender
aesthetic uh in some cultures is is a
cultural difference
some of which is describable to
differences in resources not so easily
done
in the modern era between europe and
north america right but
um in terms of um cultures in which
there are regular boom bust cycles of
food availability
preferences for you know finding beauty
in more heavy set
you know both women and men would have
been effectively
a potential way
to prevent famine not personal famine
like starvation rather
well i sort of think it's a like a tin
bergen
uh phony egg phenomenon so tin bergen
who was one of the early
brilliant ethologists i think he was
actually richard dawkins advisor
he uh did an experiment in which
there was a preference in gulls which
was his study organism
for larger eggs and what he showed was
that there was actually no
upper limit right the bigger the uh egg
didn't make any difference absurd
non-egg-like phony eggs were still
preferred in some way
even when anatomically impossible given
the size of the bird
right and so i guess what i'm it's it's
a little bit like people's uh
affinity for sugar and things it's like
there was no reason to set a limit on
how much sugar to you know
to to avoid because the presence of
arbitrarily large amounts of sugar and
the environment just isn't a thing until
industrialization um so i think it might
be something
something like that i have run into
something recently which we might want
to track down
if you haven't maybe maybe you and i
have talked about it but
there is this belief that beauty
standards have changed radically in the
west
and that is inferred from rubenesque uh
paintings in which uh
women with a great deal of what months
have been called pulchritude
um were painted but
the recent evidence suggests actually
that this may have to do
with the models who were available to
the painters not
the preferences um and so that in fact
this may have been misinterpreted
so anyway that's interesting i haven't
heard that for a topic for another time
all right um well yeah we could go we
could spend a lot more time on that but
we're going to move ahead
to our first question from last hour
is the world just a series of rigged
games within rigged games
humans create and defend rigged games
and competitors assert their own
structures and games to be rigged for
them instead
can't blame everyone for trying
well you know yes and no i would say
um you know take romance for
uh an example romance has a game
theoretic structure to it but played
well and honorably it's a collaborative
game
right there's also a way to play
in an analogous space in a predatory way
and so i guess the point is
i don't think all games are alike and
the fact that everything is reducible
to game-like structures or economic
structures or something like this
is an observation that only takes you so
far because really what we are detecting
when we see
rigged games is um that the malignant
versions of all of these things have
taken over
and so we you know if romance has
a game like nature in some way it's
playful
right that's good and the participants
may not want to emphasize in anybody's
mind that it's
game-like right it's much more
delightful not to think of it that way
at the point that you realize somebody
is playing you
it's hard not to recognize the pattern
that says oh here's the game they're
playing
and they're the winner at my expense so
i thought we were playing
not that you were playing at my expense
right and so i guess the point is what
causes us to fall out of suspension of
disbelief
mode and into game analysis mode is the
discovery that we are not
collaborating in the way that we thought
that we were and so what that means is
even though the whole landscape is games
that it is the malignant versions that
cause us to recognize it and therefore
we
tend to see games as malignant which is
just a mistake
right yeah that's good
uh no this person says christmas is not
over not here in norway
we have to wait for newt for wiping the
jewel out and he'll be here the 20th day
of christmas
also known as the 13th of december that
must mean january
that must be the 13th of january because
otherwise it would be nice
what's going on but okay uh apparently
in norway christmas is not over
um which is good i imagine it's still
pretty freaking dark in norway and you
need as much
as much christmas yuletide spirit as you
can get sure
all right next question what are your
thoughts on commercial pet diets and
vaccinations
can you share the best diets out there
what are your pets eating thank you for
spending your saturdays saturdays with
us it means a lot and it's greatly
appreciated
thank you um the pet industry
is a giant [ __ ] yeah
the pets themselves are not they're
awesome everyone should have pets if
they can
they are super wonderful and helpful in
getting through all sorts of madness but
um
veterinarians have become um
uh through no initial fault of their own
so um so responsive to market forces
unable to
make a living except by charging for all
sorts of things that animals don't need
and um and just basically being pill
pushes the way many mds are now
um you know our animals are fully
vaccinated
um but well i don't know i think i think
they're asking for one of them to get a
flu shot honestly fairfax is actually
anti-vax he just really doesn't like
shots
um yeah i actually for the first time
now i'm hearing about a flu shot for i
don't even know which
why it would be one and not all of them
maybe it's just because it's the dog and
not the cats but um no they haven't had
flu shots i don't think but they've
got all of their um lifetime or you know
eating a tighter every two or three
years shots
and they always will um because they do
spend some time
outside um pet diets
man uh you know we don't it's a disaster
it's a disaster and we you know we don't
spend the time to um
not give them commercial food because
you got to have a life
but it's a disaster and it's it's all
full of garbage and it's terrible for
them but it's not even
like full of garbage the way junk food
is full of garbage there's something
physiologically dangerous in the pet
food supply and you can just
see this in the number of pets who just
mysteriously end up having some
allergy to their food something is off
oh well your cat's just developed a
chicken allergy just developed a chicken
allergy what are you talking about
yeah cat's been eating chicken for six
years well let's just develop the
chicken
chicken which you know um so basically
what this means
is stuff that's in the gut
is being exposed to the immune system
which is not supposed to happen
this i believe is analogous to what
happened to me
with wheat yeah right and so basically
the question is what is exposing stuff
in the gut to the immune system
right that's the question and maybe it's
the same thing for the pets that's
happening to people that's causing so
many of us to be allergic to things that
we
otherwise would normally eat um
but that's the real question and you
know you've got
some kind of dysfunction and it's
especially likely to show up in pet food
because pet food is especially likely to
be less well regulated than human
yeah and it's gonna have a lot of filler
in it and the fact is
um especially for cats but also for dogs
you should expect i don't actually know
if it's true but the prediction is
that you'll have less of a problem with
the diets and the foods
of animals that are omnivores in the
wild like if you've got a rabbit
or a guinea pig or something then
if you've got one of these carnivorous
and
your pet food has any filler at all in
it you know
increasingly there's a lot of grain free
pet food available and it costs a little
bit more but that's almost certainly
worth doing
but even the non-grain free stuff has
stuff
in it that at least your cats wouldn't
be eating in the wild you know cats
don't eat sweet potatoes in the wild
yeah sorry they don't
so um it's you know is it bad for them
inherently not necessarily but is it the
sweet potato then in one of
150 cats creates a leaky gut syndrome
maybe you know probably not for dogs
dogs are more omnivorous
and they do more sharing of um
of food as well in their wild state
and so probably also have a more robust
sort of you know gut
biota um also so
boy it's a it's a disaster yep could be
could be the fillers could be the
pesticides on the crops could be
other stuff in our environment could be
off-gassing furniture that causes
uh physiological reaction that uh you
know inflammation that causes the immune
system to see stuff
you know uh we'd be wise to figure out
how to wield
uh precaution more effectively because
we are suffering from its failure
yeah i mean i guess one one thing we do
do
is um when we cook
for instance a whole bird like a turkey
or a chicken
um we
tend to not spend a ton of time getting
absolutely all the meat off the bones
we will make the carcass into stock
and then we will take that carcass after
we've pulled off all the rest of the
resource for us to use for soup or for
the base of
whatever we're going to use you know
freezing stock and then we will take all
the rest of the remaining meat and give
it to the animals
such that there's essentially no waste
and it's great for them it's
real food it's honest it's actual meat
and it doesn't have anything else in it
yeah but don't give them the bones after
you've cooked them i i don't know how
good advice that is you've certainly
been given that advice but
i don't think it's safe yeah i don't
know how dangerous it is but
um it's not the same as uh the raw bones
yeah
all right hi guys there has been
research showing that richer nations are
more accepting of gay people than poorer
nations
is there any idea why less wealthy
nations are generally less accepting
um yeah again this treads into territory
that i
i hesitate to keep kicking the can down
the road but i just think there's no um
there's no alternative i think there is
a good reason for the pattern but it
probably isn't the pattern that you
think it is in other words there's a
question of
in what way gay people are accepted
and that's all i'm going to say and we
will come back to it
when covid allows
that's right blame coven blame covid yes
all right why not it's not gonna fight
back wait no it's yeah
okay um aside from the issue of
censorship
and suggestive algorithms what risks do
you see for the common person
that is people who are not in the public
eye who continue to use instagram
following the new terms and conditions
announced in december
i'm not on instagram i don't know i mean
i assume they're doing the same
[ __ ] that everyone else is doing but i
don't know what specifically instagram
is doing
i don't either but instagram is owned by
facebook
oh right right okay this is whatsapp
facebook is on by whatsapp uh i mean i
mean i mean
facebook owns whatsapp yep yes um
so i don't know what these uh
restrictions are
in a very general sense across all
platforms there is less
risk to you if you are not dependent on
these platforms to reach your audience
or
worse to earn your livelihood
um but obviously civilization
depends on people who are reaching
audiences and earning livelihoods so
in some update instagram service and
everything
is not about that it's more about having
access to
your phone's data yeah so zach is
telling us something about instagram's
updated terms of service has something
to do with access to your phone
i know that whatsapp recently updated
their
terms of service in a similar way
allowing
facebook to access more data from you
know ostensibly what takes place on
whatsapp is encrypted
presumably it is but uh that doesn't
mean that the metadata isn't awfully
valuable
so what i would say is the smart kids
are on signal and i wouldn't use
whatsapp and
i wouldn't depend on instagram and uh we
will talk more
in future live streams and podcasts
about what wise people can do
to shore up their technical lives
because
we are behind the eight ball
why do you think rapid antigen stripe
tests were not used by any government
around the world to avoid having
lockdowns
if everyone would be able to test
themselves every day wouldn't that lower
drastically the number of infections
so rapid antigen stripe test uh as a
phrase here
looks like it might be a term of art and
i don't know it is a term of art but i
can imagine
you know what i what i think it means if
it's not a specific reference
there was talk sort of early mid i don't
know may june
about these being available and deployed
and clearly i mean we were having
conversations with people at that point
like this is what we need
um i don't know the state of whether or
not they ever became
like if they were ever if the problem
was one of development
or deployment and those two
[Music]
which one of those it is makes for a
very different
answer to why not right like were they
never developed
maybe because it actually proved to be
very very difficult um i
honestly don't know which of these is
true or were they developed but not
deployed in which case
it's going to be a political you know
it's going to be a will of the
government issue
yeah um i don't know i would say
i think there needs to be it's not
really a post-mortem
yet but there needs to be a deep
analysis of how we got
uh covid so wrong yeah and
i would say one of the huge issues for
me
is the low quality of testing in general
right the difficulty of accessing it the
slow speed
of results the uh
questionable use of pcr testing false
positives false negatives
all of these things and basically the
point is look
you know if your problem is that you're
in danger
of crashing because you're blindfolded
job number one is getting the freaking
blindfold off and
the fact of not knowing who is sick
when is making this
all the harder to deal with it is
fueling
uh irresponsible conspiracy stuff
it raises the possibility of shenanigans
being
played politically so it makes
everything more tribal right
where your mask when you're in the park
no right well i mean
you know to take one example
we have these new strains at least one
new strain that is showing up
a higher degree of transmissibility i
have not seen a good analysis on
how that works i know from studying
trade-offs that it will have borrowed
from somewhere
right it will have borrowed from
somewhere and that somewhere
could be a standard somewhere or it
could be a non-standard somewhere but
it could for example be that more
transmissible
than standard sarsko v2
is a result of the fact that it's
better able to transmit outdoors in
other words if we are lulled into a
false sense of security because the
strain that we got used to
has certain quirks that allow us to do
certain things and some virus were to
depart from that pattern
it would for a while be more
transmissible it doesn't mean that it's
more capable right it's just it will you
know maybe it's less transmissible
indoors more transmissible outdoors and
we are of a mindset where we think
outdoors is safe so i'm not saying
that's true but just
asterisk i i'm not to say it's not
possible but i have an impossible time
imagining how
a virus that transmits basically
respiratory airborne particles
um could simultaneously become more
transversable outdoors and
less indoors like i don't i don't if it
was optimal maybe some mechanism
okay let's say that this was a gain of
function escapee from
the wuhan lab the experiment
that generated it or the set of
experiments were done indoors so it
would have been
optimized inadvertently for an indoor
environment and then to the extent
that there is some sort of slider right
in which a bias towards what you're
optimized for moves towards a compromise
it's not that it would necessarily um
lose anything recognizable indoors it
would just be
slightly less tuned to it because it
would effectively had
have borrowed from its outdoor
transmissibility to get so optimized for
indoor transmissibility which is
anomalously high again i don't like it's
possible there's some mechanism
i haven't imagined but um the the high
indoor transmissibility seems to be
about this you know this this metaphor
that you've used of the bucket filling
yeah it's about boundary layers and
density of
of particles and you know you're indoor
in a room without good air flow
and there's nothing the virus can do to
change the fact that you're indoor in a
room without good air flow if someone
else is breathing out viral particles
they are going to stay in that room and
get more more dense over time as someone
continues to breathe them out if there's
not good air flow
okay so here's what here's how you do it
this is this is not
based on evidence this is just proof of
concept that something connects
can fit this space
we know that outdoor transmissibility
has been
very very low we also know that
sensitivity to uv light is very high but
we know that those two things are not
the same
property in other words even at night it
appears not to transmit outdoor so it's
not just the uv sensitivity
now suppose that what happened in these
novel strains that are more
transmissible
is that some sort of
pigment or other robustifying
element was introduced that made the
particle
more durable in the presence of uv light
but less transmissible because some
percentage of the time whatever
molecular coating it was it's heavier
and it drops faster
exactly something like that so um that
means it's not like it's lost the skill
that it had in yours it just means that
something is making it a little
more the stuff in the bucket is on the
floor you're not gonna run into it right
i mean it's exactly like
um you know uh you you take your
umbrella
into the world carrying an umbrella
makes you slightly less fast if you have
to run
and it makes you substantially
more capable of staying dry if it starts
to rain and we all know it makes it less
likely that it will rain
this is established right i quibble with
the we all know
part of that but i agree that there is
rain
that it exists it happens and sometimes
a concession i heard a concession in
there yes
yeah okay um
i'm not sure i think i'm not sure
exactly what this question means i'll
show it to you as well as i read it
hi bret and heather i am white pilled on
the capitol
it's weeds out the authoritarians within
our government and political parties
what do you think um so i think there's
just there's a typo or a missing word or
something in there and i'm also not sure
what white pilled is referring to i know
red pilled and blue pilled um we in fact
recently re-watched the matrix for the
first time in a long time with our boys
yes red white and blue pilled i also
have not heard
white pilled yeah so i don't know what
white pill means i'm not sure what the
what the rest of this means um but they
but this person asked it twice
so um so i put it in here
yeah i really wish i understood that i'm
especially confused by the idea of
it i think it's supposed to read it
weeds out the authoritarians
what weeds out the authoritarians yeah
you can but i think the rest of the
phrasing in the question is
obscure enough that it's not necessarily
going to make help
white pill the moment or series of
events by which a person abandons
despair and surrenders to the
inevitability of hope
not out of sheer optimism but from
facing difficulty and nihilism head-on
through the use of reason and inquiry it
is the final destination of those who
are red-pilled and black-pilled
and tends to happen when a person
becomes cynical of cynicism and
skeptical of skepticism
it is named after the white hot fire of
hope in a pill form and its medicine for
the soul
so is it not based on cs lewis
is it not in some way related to
uh oh one pill makes you larger and one
film makes you small no not lose carol
c.s lewis right um so it's some pill
lost in the back of the wardrobe
yeah i think it was probably his
religious and philosophical writing
rather than uh
if it is not a close kin to the first
against the wall
club right the first against the wall
club is the embrace of the idea that you
can't really protect yourself from the
authoritarianism that's coming and so
you might as well lean into it although
i gotta say you know there's a there's a
line in there in that urban dictionary
definition that zach pulled up that i
was just reading from
um abandon what was it
something about cynicism and then
something about skepticism and
you know you in your teaching used to
explicitly one of the earliest
assignments that you would give to
students in many classes was ask them to
write about define
and explain a relationship between
cynicism skepticism and faith yeah yeah
that was
uh that was one that uh turned people's
thinking on its head and it's i mean it
is brilliant and you know to
to simply object anything that comes
your way
is to have a cynical perspective and to
simply accept anything that comes your
way is to have a faithful perspective on
you know in within some context and to
be skeptical
is this middle ground which which says
uh maybe maybe not let me see what other
evidence there is and so the idea of
abandoning skepticism seems like a very
a dire choice no matter what the
conditions but certainly certainly right
now
right you know do not abandon your
skepticism now some people will disagree
resulting in a skeptic schism yes
all right that's not worth anything but
it was fun to say nothing
i didn't even know if i was going to be
able to say it i thought i might yeah
skepticism
skeptic schism skepticism yeah i
couldn't say it yeah
it's difficult are there
are there any missing links outliers or
any other deviations and species that
have made you question the core of
evolutionary theory itself and consider
alternative explanations
parentheses i'm not a creationist
yeah i would say no there are certain
californian of you yeah no no there's
there's certainly some
impressive gaps right um
now at least let's just take the gaps
amongst the living tests but the gaps
don't
don't render important uh
imagine that you have a tree
a phylogenetic tree and it has lots of
taxa on it
right and then a lot of time passes and
one of the processes is an extinction
process that leaves some
taxon isolated the other creatures
existed but they've gone and in fact
this is something
we should expect because the process of
adaptive radiation the thing that causes
an ancestor to produce a whole bunch of
species
right that's a species increase process
and then time
creates so you basically get exploration
of design space
and then you get the elimination of some
of these things which were good enough
to work for a while but not
durable to last for the long term and so
you know you can get a very
um big exploration with lots of taxa
and then you can get a lot of loss and
then if you have a process that lasts
long enough you get things like um
you know the uh order tubuli dentata
the aardvark right which is totally
alone
um well
i mean yes it is so lonely i mean there
are other aardvarks so it's not that
lonely but
that's good um but in any case so the
point is what would be surprising is if
we had uniformity
of organisms across um across time
um you know sort of demarcating every
hundred thousand years or something what
it looked like at that point like that's
you know that's not how geology works
that's
how weathering works that's not how you
know therefore the fossil record works
and it's also not how
the evolutionary process in the first
place worked so you know where are we to
find
consistent evidence with no gaps in any
way
that actually would seem to be the kind
of evidence for
a creator um that is often tried it out
is like that's what you need in order to
prove that evolution
is true it's like no that would that
would be bizarre that would be
statistically
so unlikely impossible yeah all but
impossible
um so you know there are things we
mentioned on our last podcast i
think the um clade that includes
hyraxes which is something that looks
like a rodent it's not
but uh hyraxes elephants and
um sirenians uh don't they
nice teeth uh they do have very pointy
teeth and what they don't have is
rodent-like teeth so the diagnostic
characteristic of
uh rodents is these ever-growing
incisors which the
hyraxes don't have but anyway and they
like canines rodents
rodents lack canines diagnostically and
higher axes don't
true um now the point is
elephants manatees
and hyraxes that's a pretty widely
separated group
of taxes they don't have similar niches
in
any way they're each other's closest
living relatives but that doesn't mean
that they
um you know they could interbreed right
oh yeah
not remotely close enough for that so
anyway those sorts of gaps
are natural and we have them but the
other thing that you and i have
we are old enough as biologists to have
seen gaps that
seemed impossibly large get closed by
fossil discoveries and in fact we were
lucky enough
to be at the university of michigan when
phil gingrich came back with his initial
fossil finds that um showed exactly what
creationists used to mock evolutionists
about which was the claim that whales
uh were anglets
and so uh the whales had returned to the
sea it was a secondary return to the sea
from an ungulate ancestor right and so
there used to be
creationist uh literature mocking
evolutionists in which you know a
whale on legs was wandering to the sea
which is of course nonsense but what
uh phil gingrich found were fossils in
which you had
whales that had legs that were in the
process of being reduced
over time and there are now quite a
number of these fossils i would point
just as you have
uh tiny little femurs in very basil
extent
snakes early in development like boweds
boats have tiny tiny little femur bones
early in development because they are
lizards that lost their legs they're not
the only taxonom but the most specious
taxon that did
um so anyway this is uh so we were we
were there phil gingrich was um
at the university of michigan phil
gingrich found the fossils newt gingrich
has never found a significant fossil in
his entire career
yeah and and guess what you're going to
love this those two gingrich's
spelled differently what i know oh man
all right yeah i knew you'd like that
one okay
trump's ban will directly hurt free
speech in authoritarian regimes like
russia they'll justify harsher
censorship and restrictions by pointing
to the u.s
i incidentally writing this and from
russia love you both thank you
um yeah it's uh yeah
that's right this is a huge setback
um for for all of us yeah
um man there's so many five yeah um
okay so we had a ton of questions this
last hour um
and we're not going to get to a majority
of them including many many good ones i
will read one more here and then we'll
move into the questions from the next
hour
to what extent do you think that
overfeeding the algorithm
leads to capital storming and blm riots
over feeding that's what that's what it
says probably means overfitting
oops um
i think there is a kind of i think so
i'm going to just guess it what this
question means okay
i think the question means to what
extent does verificationism
result in things like storming of the
capital and what else
uh and the black lives matter riots the
extremists on both sides
um i i think it it accounts for a huge
amount of it and that basically the
point is you've got a
chaotic noisy environment in which that
which is captured on film and that which
isn't is arbitrarily distributed and if
your mindset is looking for evidence of
let's say rampant white supremacy
you'll find it if you do a scientific
analysis that says
is there rampant white supremacy you
won't and so
we are all born uh uh
verificationists that's the natural
thing to be
you have to learn the sophistication of
being a falsificationist which greatly
upgrades your ability to sort
pattern from noise and um
people who are not aware of that
uh and just simply are looking around
trying to make sense of the world
naturally default
into verificationism which makes them
easy prey for those who are selling
overly neat stories yeah and so yes i
think it plays a huge role
that's right um okay zach did you put a
line in here for me or
should i figure out i don't i'm not
seeing it
oh wow yeah we had a lot of questions um
okay first question from the next hour
after
a no question contribution of in the
amount of 42 dollars
thank you so we've already got our
answer
isn't the only story what nothing sorry
isn't the only story here why the
capital wasn't defended by more than a
few mall cops
and the question why was that allowed to
happen
it is certainly a question um
and it's one i have asked and wondered
about um there are of course nefarious
possible answers and i
for i don't think mall cops is the yeah
that's not that's not a fair description
yeah
you had the capitol police who were
overwhelmed
you have the question of why there was
not and then you had i think virginia
state police who were brought in in
large numbers
and there's a question about why the
national guard was not present early on
um and i don't think we know the answers
to this i am not convinced that
in an environment in which this event is
you know the lightning rod in a
polarizing debate over um you know
how authoritarian to be and who is
allowed to speak
i'm not convinced we're going to get a
fair analysis of what took place
yeah you know it's hard enough with
something like
covid which ought to be completely
non-partisan
and it's slow like that that's a
slow-moving
nightmare yeah as opposed to you know
some hours
of chaos and i mean i think so it sounds
like the conversation that you had this
the second conversation that you have
posted at our course podcast that you
had with jeremy quinn
yesterday yeah is now is now up he's now
live on youtube and and he he as someone
who was on the ground
i don't haven't listened to your
conversation yet but uh does he speak to
what he saw as the police presence
there yes and he says you know i mean he
says a number of things about um
being surprised as he so apparently
there was no
ability to communicate uh cell phones
were not functioning
at the time because there were so many
people present so the cell architecture
was overwhelmed
but he was very shocked to discover how
the
event had been cast in racial terms
when he got back to the internet
um and he was shocked at the portrayal
about the police um effectively having
let this whole thing happen and yeah
it's nonsense as a portrayal that he
saw um push back and you know he saw a
lot of
variation and that basically that's a
cherry-picked
um analysis which doesn't explain why
there wasn't sufficient police presence
to prevent it
but he the idea that police just let
this happen he says it's nonsense
does birth order rather than mom's age
influence the occurrence of gestational
diabetes
is it a heritage of interaction between
mom and previous embryos
what else can be influenced by previous
embryos homosexuality
um super this is from echo super
interesting question i do not know the
answer specifically with regard to
gestational diabetes
it is known that
um embryos leave markers
in mom and um
i believe boy doing this off the top of
my head i think the evidence for that is
that
um women who carry
male fetuses uh
end up having some some
why chromosome produced stuff
circulating in them
even after they've given birth or that
shows up again at the point that they
become pregnant again i don't remember
exactly what it is
um so i don't the idea that
homosexuality is about something
happening in the womb
seems unlikely to me we don't we don't
need we you just don't need to go there
to explain sort of birth order effects
and
um well there is a birth order effect
but to explain per third effects you
don't need to go to gestational stuff
yeah right with regard to homosexuality
well i'm not i guess i'm not sure i
don't know that we need a physiological
explanation but it is certainly very
interesting the older brother right hand
rule which has been demonstrated
multiple times
says the more older brothers you have
the more
likely you are to be gay if you're male
so long as you're right-handed
it's a fascinating pattern that does not
imply that it is a
physiological um distortion of the birth
environment or something like that in
fact i think it's probably
a uh an adaptive pattern in which
you know something about the natal home
right yeah
i mean the prediction the prediction of
what what i was alluding to and what you
are now stating explicitly that there's
no reason to think it's gestational
the prediction would be that um a
later-born
right-handed son who was adopted out at
birth
would not be would not have an enhanced
likelihood of
be being homosexual well but i i leave
open the pi i mean it's possible this is
known
and i just haven't looked into it
recently enough to know the answer but
um it could well be gestational but it
doesn't have to be a distortion of the
environment
now there there is a set of processes
that will distort the environment which
has to do with the work
of david hague primarily
about the conflict of interest between
mothers
and fetuses over resources and i would
point out
most of you are probably not going to
know what the hell i'm talking about
here but
i would point out that the conflict of
interest exists it is inherent to the
fact that the mother and the offspring
are not a
100 percent related to each other
but the degree of that conflict is
very different in the case of
a monogamous bond in which all siblings
are full siblings rather than
a poliginous polygamous
or a promiscuous system in which
siblings are presumed to be
half siblings so let me just provide an
actual example from i think higgs
probably that first 1993 paper although
he's done a tremendous amount of work as
of others since then
uh which found that so it's it's about
um genes being imprinted
the idea is that genes actually um
retain and i'm going to speak as if
they're conscious and of course they're
not
retain a marker of which parent they
came from
and so you can have a maternally
imprinted gene that is identical in
terms of its spelling
to a paternally imprinted gene except
that one of them came from mom and one
of them came from dad
and that the these different alleles
maternally imprinted versus paternally
imprinted
will code for different kinds of for
instance rates of development
in the developing fetus wherein a mother
with a fetus inside of her wants very
much for that child
to thrive and survive but is also
interested
in her own health long term and her
ability to continue to produce more
children down the road
less so that analysis changes the closer
to the end of her reproductive life she
is
and the father of that fetus if they are
in
if he is in a pure-bonded relationship
with a mother has a
very coincident interest as as the
mother does
but if this was a this is a one-off
thing
and the baby is never going to meet its
dad
the paternally imprinted genes in that
baby
have an interest in that kid laying on
as much as fat as possible and
getting as big a head as possible before
it's born which renders it more likely
to be more successful after birth
but also renders it less likely to
provide its mother with an easy birth
and more likely to actually harm its
mother on birth and so you get
maternally imprinted genes
pulling resources slightly away from the
kid
so that mom is more likely to survive
birth intact and be able to produce more
kids later
and paternally imprinted genes
especially in polygynous societies
pulling towards putting more and more uh
developmental
speed on the kids when they're still in
utero such that
the maternal health is downgraded
relative to fetal health
so uh in effect what you have is
an arms race between fetus and mother
and this results
in fetus which has access to the
mother's
bloodstream uh using chemical signals to
try to increase the liberation of
resources
and the mother turning down her
sensitivity to those messages so that
she doesn't over
uh can't hear you right but the point is
you get these two systems you know you
get something broadcasting too loud and
something not listening at all
and the point is this is uh at least one
of the root causes
of the illnesses that go along with
gestation
um i would also point out though um this
is such a deep rabbit hole but um yeah
we're not really getting at the question
but hopefully echo will be satisfied
with this
um in effect you have uh
what we have described as the two
reproductive modes of males
one of them is collaborative and the
other is predatory and the point is the
predatory one results in
uh things including uh gestational
uh disease um because
the a male who has a one-off sexual
encounter
with a female does not have an interest
in her future offspring doing well in
fact they're competitors with the
offspring he's producing
so it is inherently uh
of a very different type which goes back
to our discussion earlier
of different kinds of games
collaborative and competitive games and
you know unfortunately we're stuck with
a situation in which
love and romance are being pushed in the
direction of this predatory game
which is part of the reason that the
landscape is so dysfunctional yeah let's
play games but let's make it
collaborative
yeah deal all right
um brett that's all
no
brett have you considered if capitalism
is one of those things which helps us
when we're young and
kills us when we're old why are we
allowed to cherry pick the bible
and vice versa for marx
i think the vice versa for marx means um
helps us when we're young no hurts us
when we're young and helps us when we're
old
uh no
so there's three things here i'm not
sure what the vice versa for marx is
referring to the bible or
to capitalism in this case well
so not a lot we are allowed to cherry
pick in the bible in fact you have to to
get a coherent story because it's
self-inconsistent um but with marx
you're not allowed to
take the good and dispense with the bad
which i i agree with that there's some
there's some valuable stuff in the
marxist analysis well and we're talking
about
that prescription yeah needing um some
systems that are socialized
without um in any way arguing for a
an entirely socialized society yeah so
my quibble here is going to be that the
and i think i just went through this on
the
trigonometry podcast i hesitate anytime
anybody wants to attribute anything to
capitalism because i don't know what
they mean
right and i think the thing is if
capitalism is as broad as markets
then um you can't dispense with it and
so
you know markets are a gift they need to
be well enough regulated that they don't
produce
massive amounts of harm which was half
which is what happens when you don't
regulate them but
in any case um yes the process you're
alluding to
where processes involved in our markets
and i would say the interaction between
our markets and our political system
cause this senescence-like
process where things that are profitable
early and have
massive laid harms tend to be
unstoppable right that's the process
we've described now earlier this week i
had a
another thought which i need to flesh
out a little bit about the other side of
this process which i didn't realize
which is
that there's a tension in uh
in bodies which
mirrors a tension in governance that is
the driving force that causes this
uh this senescence process so it has to
do with uh
continuity of governance in the
civilization case being analogous to
um things like tumor surveillance in uh
in bodies but anyway you just learn that
later you just said that the deep state
is to
tumor surveillance as governments are to
bodies
um no let's put it this way tumors are
bad
the things that correct for tumors
cause us to grow age and to grow feeble
with age and fall apart
and that uh all of the
that the whole thing has an analogy to
the civilization context
and i believe all you would need to do
is
get it and then spend enough time to
realize that it's true
to recognize where we have to go that
this process
the games we are playing in political
space cannot possibly address this
problem and
the end is coming if we don't
escape this story well that sounds like
that should move to the top of your
to-do list
uh yeah it's a pressing yeah okay
because i don't
to me i have not yet that doesn't yet
sound operational
but um well we've talked about the
solution the solution involves
the recognition that uh the values of
our system
um need to be rescued from the vessel
which is out of date
and so you know instead of the
constitution sucks or the constitution
is sacred
the values okay but rescued from the
vessel which is out of date
is not operational in terms of what new
vessel shall be created and how
the equivalent of a child we need to
have the new system
born from the old system before the old
system dies
anyway it's for frontier stuff yeah it's
just it's
i think you and i may disagree about
what operational means
well um let's put it this way i
you certainly wouldn't want um i think
the recognition of the process and the
broad brush
that suggests what we have to do you
know revolutionary change without
revolution
that that's about as operational as you
need to get because until we're all on
board with that idea
you don't need the operational it's you
know it's like
spending a lot of time uh terraforming
mars before you have a rocket that can
get you there
i'm not sure i agree with the analogy
but maybe
all right um do you think the uk's
appointed for life house of lords
gives us some protection against
rent-seeking and combative politics that
your senate
does not um
yes yeah it will it will have both
benefits of this type which is of course
why our supreme court is appointed for
life
um and it will have costs right um and
you know none of these structures is
perfect and
it's it's all trade-offs yep
phylomemetic
analyses have been seen for legislation
originated from originating from
alec uh caps who can provide such
analyses for the patriot act
and the upcoming response to january 6th
uh what was the alec connection there i
well i got to remember what alec is alec
was a
corporate legislation writing process i
think
yeah so i will i'll look it up but uh
phylomemetic it's not a word i've ever
heard before phylomemetic analyses have
been seen for legislation
originating from alec who can provide
such analyses for the patriot act
and the upcoming response to i see so
what they're saying
is that one can deduce the source of
legislation by looking at
elements of the way it's phrased
basically that you can deduce
uh heritage um
what does alex stand for uh american
legislative exchange council
and right at the top of their page they
have the alex statement on the events of
january 6
2021 so
the question is a good one which is when
you have these diabolical pieces of
legislation
how much can you figure out about where
they actually came from and therefore
whose interests are being represented
um so yes i think it's a great idea and
i don't know who can
produce it but it should be a it should
be somebody's focus
somebody good yeah
uh heather nailed it with the word
futility do you have any recommendation
for how to help
volunteering or is there a pill i can
take so i can learn to stop worrying and
love the new world order
yeah we're all huey lewis now yeah he's
got a new drug
we do and it just never shows up ever
um yeah
look yes the the remedy
to the extent there is one is just the
recognition that um
we're all in it together right that's
kind of that's where the comfort comes
from
and the horror of it is you know
there's nothing to be done about it
other than to confront it so
uh i think this goes back to what you
read of tiknot han and
the uh the question earlier about
white pills and the even earlier
allusion to the first against the wall
club but the point is okay
let's stop avoiding the obvious
authoritarians are on the march they're
jeopardizing
everything on which we depend and we
don't have any choice
but to prevent them
from trying to bring about their utopia
which will of course be
dystopian in a novel and yet highly
familiar way
yep all right um how long where did you
say we're at sac
um okay um
let's do these next three two of them
are really just comments
and then we'll close up for the week
wouldn't the capital attack be terrorism
given oxford's definition
quote the unlawful use of violence and
intimidation especially against
civilians in the pursuit of political
aims
the mob did want to intimidate the
politicians did they not
um well and you were saying that
basically there's a legal standard
for which which
terrorism has a legal definition and the
fact that the oed
may say i assume this is the oed's
definition may say something that does
not fit that legal standard doesn't mean
that the legal standard doesn't exist
it's not even a legal definition i would
say
what it is is a trigger of a
an other world in which all protections
are suspended because it is the most
frightening thing in the universe
and i guess my point would be we have
protections for a reason
the idea that anything should cause us
to suspend
all of them that thing ought to be
something on which
a huge number of eyes who are beyond
reproach
are you know if the aliens
are pointing a weapon at the earth right
do we want people you know do we want
constitutional protections to prevent us
from doing what we need to do in order
to fend off the aliens
no but the point is the chances of a
circumstance in which
you're actually better off suspending
your constitutional protections because
of this that or the other
are pretty low now in the case of you
know kovid
do we need to prioritize some things
over
certain civil liberties for a short
period of time yeah we probably did and
we blew it
but the point is you can't have a term
that everybody thinks they know what it
means and everybody is using it to
describe
anything that they think is really bad
right and then it triggers this legal
suspension of all sorts of stuff and
most diabolical of all when you start
delving into what the trigger
causes to move into motion the fisa
courts and warrants um you know
basically you've got
this um these powers
housed in the executive which are
absolutely dictatorial
and so anyway i don't think it's a
definitional issue
i think it's a you've got an emergency
escape
hatch from the most essential stuff that
makes our civilization
really awesome and the protections that
go with it
ought to be you know absolutely
top-notch and have nothing to do with
whether we intuitively feel that
something is terrorism because
you know were those people trying to
intimidate legislature legislators
i can make that argument but you know if
i was trying to intimidate
legislators would i put on a fanciful
viking hat like you know i just
it's hard to get into the brain of that
guy i don't know it is but but i mean
actually you know he had a youtube
channel which is now suspended but
well that's a shock but my point is
could in a world where nothing special
happened
when you triggered the word terrorism
could a reasonable person reach the
conclusion
that these people were engaged in that
yes reasonable people could disagree
in a world where that is the magic word
that causes legal protections to
evaporate
is it so clearly terrorism that that
thing ought to be triggered no
freaking way so anyway
like that okay two last uh
questions comments i can't wait for the
woke to force trumpers to wear orange
armbands emblazoned with a big golden
letter t
are you both excited for re-education
always
that's from our old friend i'll fight
you naked
um yes not excited for re-education no
um it doesn't suit either of us very
well the people who are
hell-bent on re-education don't seem to
know very much about the actual world
and they
um seem to have a chip on their shoulder
so yeah i'm not looking forward to it
and finally no questions this is this is
a great
full circle from the beginning of the
first hour here today no questions just
an acknowledgement of heartfelt
gratitude for this conversation
your words provide us with the courage
to carry on thank you and your sons and
fur people
thank you for the people yes
some of which the fur has inhaled a bit
more further than
the optimal exactly um thank you
we uh i think reminding ourselves
of what we have to be grateful for and
being explicit about our gratitude
is very important right now always but
especially
right now yeah gratitude catitude and
attitude i would say
i i'm reminded of pasta rasta disaster
which was the trilogy in the
caribbean landscape where i did a season
of field work
um and so you said gratitude attitude
cattitude i believe catitude was second
i'm not ready to go down with the ship
over that one but uh yeah
you know i think it it's possible but it
may be
kind of niche the way rasta pasta
disaster pasta disaster yeah i remember
that place
um uh so question before we sign off
here yeah
very often we uh figure out what the
titles of these episodes should be after
we reflect on what we've said
you want to do that live well there's a
quick question
there's something that didn't get said
in the first hour but that might have
and i'm wondering if it would be a
suitable title and if we talk about it
here then to the extent
that it leaves people scratching their
heads there will be an answer that they
can
readily avail themselves of perhaps
perhaps what is it
tyranny comes at you fast what do you
think
it does yes it does all right well we
will talk about whether or not that
might be a
a title um if you're puzzling over such
things
all right um announcements a we
did not intend to release the jeremy lee
quinn
first-hand report from the assault on
the capital in the middle of our live
stream here but the
report is so timely that we felt it was
necessary to get it to you as quickly as
possible
so if you would spread the word about
the 60-second live stream
check out the jeremy lee quinn podcast
which is
really part three of my conversation
with him part two will be emerging
next week we may be numerically
challenged here at darkhorse podcast
we are historically challenged in the
sense that tyranny comes at you so
fast that there is sometimes have to
report
on things as they happen and then go
back to editing zachary the
tyranny is not a wit about integers it
does not it does
it get tyranny gives a half wit
it provides many houses many half widths
they are you
empowers the halfwitch all right
so yeah join us at our patreons
please consider doing so we do a private
q a once a month the last sunday of the
month
um at mime uh where we can actually
engage with the people on chat
and then we leave that up for um anyone
to look at who's who's on the patreon at
any time in the future
brett has monthly conversations on his
that are quite wonderful you've been
doing those
since you started your patreon back in
the summer of 2017.
absolutely i've met some great people
yeah
really amazing people uh you can
um you should consider being a member of
the first against the wall club
for which you do not need to have any
evidence but there is
stuff that you could get that has that
image on it
at the store at
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
um holly pointed out on twitter that uh
it was a good match for the events of
the
um of this past week my friend yes
okay cool but again you can draw up your
own
emblem for the first against the wall
club that's right and um
we have we got a great guy making clips
for from these
episodes uh and i'm sure he will be
creating some interesting ones from this
week so
uh check out the dark horse podcast
clips channel as well
and we will see you next week yeah one
more thing
i would say one thing that we should be
doing there are many things we should be
doing we will revisit the question but
um i got it what is it going outside
oh yeah go outside definitely do that
but what i was going to suggest
is one hedge against this uh
rapidly marching authoritarian
tyrannical impulse
is for us to start making sure that we
follow
people if you follow me follow heather
vice versa
so that to the extent that somebody gets
shut out of an environment
there's some other place through which
they can get messages into the world so
yeah so also darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com
is a is a portal in to um
you know ask logistical questions really
but um we
probably should be re-upping our
looking into alternative platforms just
in case just in case
the purge continues i mean maybe it'll
stop maybe it's where you stopped
yep i just can't see that happening but
hopefully it will
hopefully these crazed maniacs will come
to their senses
and stop the purge and realize what
values it is that
actually keep the west together all
right
let's keep talking even when we disagree
and get outside
okay be well everyone see you next time
[Music]
you